y
cubría mi mesilla
los partidarios de ibrahim raeissi están
felices su candidato acaba de ganar las
elecciones presidenciales iraníes
[Música]
el presidente electo quien encabezaba el
poder judicial es un ultraconservador
cercano al guía supremo alí jamenéi la
mayoría de los militantes presentes para
festejar la victoria son conservadores
para los cuales votar es un deber
religioso venido a participamos en la
elección para honrar la memoria del
mártir sobrehumano y estamos felices de
que nuestro candidato haya ganado
estamos felices de que el señor rice y
se vuelva nuestro presidente y que el
gobierno del señor rohan y se termine
[Música]
raíz y ganó con el 62% de los votos pero
la tasa de abstención ha sido histórica
más de la mitad de los iraníes no
acudieron a las urnas el consejo de los
guardianes un órgano cercano al guía
supremo invalidó la candidatura de los
jefes reformistas y moderados muchos
iraníes consideraron que la elección ya
estaba jugada llegamos a ensanchar una
ciudad conservadora del sur de teherán
para reunirnos con la ley de 25 años
quien eligió no votar está desempleado a
pesar de su diploma en derecho y pasa
sus días ayudándole a sus padres en el
restaurante familiar
inglés y trabajo en esto aquí en milán
es por dinero just for money
vote por rice y fue elegido
bote era mi deber vivo en este país y
debo votar por el futuro de mensajes
los padres de 'la y conservadores no
saben que su hijo se abstuvo
no no lo hiciste no sabía estás
tranquilo es tu punto de vista
es un punto de vista
en realidad los jóvenes están molestos
por el estado del país la mayoría de los
jóvenes no votaron pero yo creía de
todas formas también había votado
la familia acaba de renovar el
apartamento ubicado arriba del
restaurante los padres de alice son
fervientes musulmanes y malí se define
como religioso va a la mezquita una vez
a la semana y sigue siendo afín a los
principios de la revolución islámica y
bailando si no vote no es porque no a mi
país
este sistema le gusta este sistema en
realidad es porque tengo rabia visto y
molesto este gobierno
elegimos gobiernos hace 4 años 8 años y
12 años todos elegimos para que trabajen
por nosotros pero no lo hicieron
esta rabia que sienten numerosos iraníes
proviene ante todo de la situación
económica las sanciones occidentales la
corrupción y el coronavirus combinaron
sus efectos y doblegaron al país los
precios están por los aires en el
mercado y más de un tercio de la
población corre el riesgo de caer bajo
el umbral de la pobreza según el banco
mundial estoy obligado a arrendar mi
vivienda tengo tres hijos no tengo
trabajo desde hace dos años los precios
han subido mucho
no puedo seguir así dicen que mejorará
pero en realidad la situación empeora
[Música]
al y está en el mercado con su madre y
su hermana para comprar los aliños para
el restaurante
estas son las flores de azafrán
desconozco el precio y cuánto cuesta
cuesta más o menos 400 toman el kilo los
precios en irán aumentan todos los días
si usted compra un kilo de este aliño
por ejemplo hoy pagará ciento manes pero
si vuelve mañana serán 120 es como un
juego de vídeo los controlan
tan sólo cambian el jugador un día es el
señor román y otro día es el señor reid
y un día el señor finney seniat nosotros
los jugadores y ellos los entrenadores
del coche
con la llegada de raíz y los
ultraconservadores controlan las tres
ramas del gobierno ejecutivo judicial y
legislativo numerosos iraníes temen un
recorte de las libertades individuales
en especial las de las mujeres
en irán la ley estipula que las mujeres
deben llevar el velo en los lugares
públicos hoy en día existen lugares en
los que se tolera cierta flexibilidad
dar band es una estación de montaña
donde los habitantes de teherán pueden
relajarse lejos del ruido y la polución
este grupo de mujeres dos hermanas y sus
tres hijas vinieron a pasear y tomar el
té rápidamente dejan caer el velo
no
el velo es obligatorio estamos obligadas
a llevarlo pero aquí cuando cae lo
dejamos en nuestros hombros
este el botón
no no vote y tú
[Música]
no yo tampoco
la ley i manilles las madres temen que
los religiosos en el poder impongan
llevar el chador el velo largo de las
ultra conservadoras
yo no llevaré puesto el chador no
volveré a salir de casa las mujeres ya
no irán a trabajar el país estará
paralizado no lo llevaremos puesto nos
detendrán nos lo quitaremos no lo
llevaremos puesto incluso yo me opongo a
mucha relajación pero el chador por
ningún motivo
por ahora el presidente bryant rising no
se ha pronunciado sobre eventuales
restricciones a las libertades
individuales anuncia concentrar sus
esfuerzos en la reactivación económica
una necesidad para tratar de obtener el
apoyo de la mayoría de los iraníes que
decidió no votar